thank you for being on my first show
Dwayne thank you for having me
as I said before the break you hadn't
actually planned on being here your baby
brother Kevin Hart was so because that's
what you call him your baby brother yeah
he was supposed to be here but he was in
a car next week ago so everything's good
with him now though right everything is
good I spoke with Kevin I actually
referred to him as my son
um
I I connected with him today and you
know what these things happen in life
and thankfully he uh was strapped in
nicely to his car seat so I think that
everything
oh
no that's right that's real love that's
real love God listen I'm only kidding if
you spoke to the pediatrician and he
said uh
oh God he's doing very well he's bummed
he couldn't be here as you know but look
I love the guy he's one of my best
friends and and honestly I mean thank
God it could have been could have been a
lot worse so he's a lucky man and I'm so
happy he's you know yeah and he's
and he knows it too and I wish him the
best and speedy recovery and um I'm
gonna see him soon and you too have the
best chemistry you're right we got a
good chemistry I mean I love every film
you've done together like I love y'all
and Jumanji I'm gonna be real with you
okay Dwayne when I saw it when I saw the
preview that they were doing another
Jumanji I was like that's not a good
idea I was like because like the
original was so good but yours was
amazing like I was I freaked thank you
so much we have seen it so much my
family my kids we all they love the part
where the hippo eats Jack Black every
time but yeah yeah it's weird I don't
want kids like that that's weird but all
kids love that part by the way yes they
love that part it's a little Jeffrey
Dahmer but yeah yeah you'll go with it
yeah I go with it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]